[Music]  Valentine for three and a break  fastball delivered well it's got to get  the toes down you gotta be in the back  of the endzone  now with the run-out karl-anthony towns  block to al-qaeda market Huskies  [Applause]  but no one wants to get in the way of  that yeah it'll be bouncing and he's  going hard to the hole here's where  you're taking the ball to the basket  I'm finger roll authority attack  [Applause]  but a great reaction from DeMarcus  Cousins  LaRhonda  [Music]  he's putting his head down and he is  determined to get to the basket my  goodness I'm not sure what you do with  that still Christy Jim Walker - Marcus  country DeMarcus Cousins is moving  without the basketball  [Music]  so they shoots the truth too slippery is  something  whose balls scooped up how about cousins  behind the back a big step back side  pray Wow  how do you guard that  lines up in cloaks with authority  [Music]